all right hot breath averse
welcome back to hot breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
we are on a mission
to cultivate the next generation of
great comics by interviewing today's
great comics and our guest today
has really blazed a trail for so many
comics to learn from he was an
emmy-winning journalist
that became a stand-up discovered a
character in his stand-up and instead
of taking voice lessons like people in
the industry were telling him he's like
never mind i'll just
post videos every day and then see what
happens and now the rest
is just viral history and he has one of
the most well-known
social media accounts in this comedy
game and we're excited to learn all
about
how we can do the same so take notes and
prepare yourselves for mr charlie
barron's everyone let's give it up for
charlie
thanks for having me absolutely thank
you for doing this
man you you really like just to jump
right into it
it's now more than ever with the
pandemic
i i mean i was booked all last year all
like i was that was my first year where
i was like oh i'm like
i'm like a working consistent comic i'm
like headlining clubs i'm like
doing the job and then it all evaporates
and now i'm like
well what now like i've doubled down on
this podcast but now i'm in this mindset
of like well where
what is what is my manitowoc like minute
what is what is my thing you know like
how how were you able to i know you did
a lot
to try it but maybe for comics what what
can we do to start to find as you say
you're tapped into a voice in your head
and just started to do it a lot how can
we find our voice in our head
well you know i think it's all about
kind of
finding your niche i guess i i got to a
point where i was doing red carpet
reporting and all that sort of stuff
and because i was doing hosting i was
doing news i was doing a bunch of other
things but
the red carpet stuff was kind of what
really pushed me
into stand up because i you know there's
nothing really more so sucking than
red carpet reporting uh and so and so
that really pushed me to do stand-up and
when i was doing stand-up i was like you
know
what's unique about me uh and and
what distinguishes me from like every
other
comic that i'm seeing and part of it was
just my news background
and but that wasn't too relatable so i
was like okay what makes it relatable oh
i always messed up the way i said things
on air
so then i just developed this character
that doubled down on everything that
people said was wrong about him
and then um what ended up happening is
it found
the niche of the that midwest niche and
it was just it's sort of underserved you
know they're a bunch of
comedians from the south but the midwest
didn't have a ton
so and i noticed that uh because
the first video i released on it it just
exploded it did great and that was after
trying a bunch of videos
that didn't do well so i was like i'm
going to do a video a week a sketch a
week
until i find my thing or whatever and i
think that's like a good practice
because it gets you in the habit of
of creating every week and putting
something out
and then what's good about that is
you don't just when you don't just find
your thing right away you kind of
stumble upon it
but in that process of stumbling you
become really good at the act of
creating
so when something takes up you're ready
to put up
another video the next week and that
video has you know
you've done enough reps that that next
video will probably be better
so i think that's kind of the idea of
creating um consistently
gets you good creation and then how that
translates to stand up is
nobody really cares how good your stand
up is
and this unfortunately but nobody cares
when they're booking you how good your
stand up is
you can be the you cannot even do stand
up i got friends who
haven't even done stand-up or hadn't
done stand-up they booked a tour
and then they wrote a performance for a
stage now if it's bad
you know if it's bad you can only do
that once but
you know if you're already a stand-up
and you have that skill set
already baked in really it's just about
getting the videos to take off
and uh with your following you can book
theaters you can book whatever you want
so it's kind of a backdoor uh way into
stand-up uh you don't have to
hustle as much on stage i guess or
opening for people
it's sort of a cheat if you will from a
stand-up perspective to
headline you know well there there can
be like
some some like og comics or like these
social media kids
taking our weekends you know they're
like the club only has 52 weeks and half
of them are these social media kids but
it's like
it's like get with it you know get
whether to get run over at the end of
the day
like it's evolving and now more than
ever you are seeing people
blow up on social media with a character
and then they have a show
of that character and that that's almost
becoming
it's almost becoming the new style of
stand-up in a sense yes there's the bill
burrs and people like that but like
the next wave it seems like how you
stand out is you find what's unique
about you
and just kind of build a show around
that
yeah yeah and and let me just also
reiterate
so much respect for you know the
comedians who do it like the old
school way i think it's harder
personally but
yeah why not use the tools at your
disposal and
if you know while you're building your
com
your standup career it makes sense to
build your
video career because a lot of bits every
bit you do on stage could be a
sketch you know and the idea there is
just basically is it relatable
um is it relatable to someone scrolling
so it's a little different like it's got
to be
the the idea or the sketch headline or
whatever
has to be enough to stop someone's thumb
from moving up
in a system that's constantly
perpetuating it to move up so it's tough
but at the end of the day it's all fun
because it's all creating in some
aspect and as long as you're doing that
you're doing the right thing
how did you get how did you get over
that mental block because i've i've had
days where i'm like all right
this is the day i'm posting a skit or
this is the day i'm even just gonna hold
up my phone and talk into it and then
i'm
i'll like go to bed with that intention
as i wake up excuses
start oh as soon as i wake up they're
like well you shouldn't that's dumb
or whatever like how do you how do you
block that critic and just
create you know it's it's about
i think just saying okay every week
i'm putting out a video or whatever it
is whatever is attainable
and start with something super
attainable start with tick tock tick
tock is a platform though
it has so many problems and whatever
it's it
it is one of the platforms where you can
grow
quickest and um you can
it's like the trends are just different
uh improv games you know so a lot of
people do improv and you go ucb and it's
like this is the game for this
bit you know that's basically what
tick-tock is with
its trends it's like how funny can you
make this
in this um time frame or whatever and
then you
see sort of also tick tock i think is on
the
front edge of like new comedy
like comedy that a bunch of us will look
at initially be like that's not comedy
that's not even funny
you know uh but there are so many
different ways to use the tool
to make it funny so it's not that
tick-tock isn't funny i mean they're
probably spying on everything that's
going on your phone that's what they're
doing well but so are all the
uh social media gens but um
but yeah just just giving you different
avenues to think creatively it's
basically giving you a box to work out
of
i don't know if i'm explaining this in
the most coherent way but
yeah i mean basically yeah what i'm
hearing is just set a
super low attainable goal if it's a if
it's a skid a week if it's just a video
of you talking every week
about whatever it's just set an
attainable goal and the more you do it
the better you'll get at the more
comfortable you'll get at it exactly and
you'll get
that momentum too of like oh i
accomplished this i can accomplish that
and then uh slowly you know people will
respond to something
and then as soon as people are
responding the comments you reply back
to them and now you have
fans and you kind of build it and snow
snowballs hopefully
you know what were some of the early
ideas you had that you said didn't work
what were you trying
uh just it was like a lot of one-off
sketches
it was sort of um political comedy there
was just a lot of political comedy out
there at the time
or you know kind of the jon stewart
thing everyone was doing the jon stewart
thing so
um and then uh
yeah just one-off sketches that were
like
like i did sort of a fifa uh
sketch i remember which i thought was
really funny
but it took a long time to produce and
it wasn't
the most um like relatable
necessarily you know but it's funny for
people who know about fifa
basically so um you know i was just
trying different
topics it was more uh topical i guess
as opposed to um just
you know finding a uh a culture i guess
to uh serve is that fifa the one that
took you 60 hours
to make yeah it took me a while yeah i
remember hearing your interviews say
like you you spent 60 hours on some
videos that got nothing and then like
20 minutes on one that'll like blow up
yeah
yeah and that one that took 20 minutes
was
i if jack dawson was from wisconsin
which was just as
it was actually a stand-up bit that i
couldn't get to work
very well on stage so i i was like but
it's funny
and i was like what if i could just make
a video and show that on
well why don't i just make a video you
know so that's kind of where that came
from
yeah what what struck me and i i my add
took me into the 60 hour thing but like
you said you were working on more
topical videos as opposed to something
you said culture or something you said
another word
there but um uh oh i i think serving a
culture
serving a culture yeah yeah so i mean
that's
you know taking okay it's the stand-up
thing right like what
what's the first thing you do when you
come up with your stand-up set or
you know i mean a wave a lot of people
started writing 10 facts about
themselves so it's kind of like
in that same 10 facts you write about
yourself is there
that's what you know the best so is
there a
niche in there that's underserved or
that really you know
speaks to you or that you just like
writing jokes about
i mean it's just a good place to start
and uh
give yourself a platform uh to grow from
i guess
you know yeah that could almost be a
good place to start for a comic
struggling is like
okay list 10 facts about you and then
for the next
10 weeks or the next 10 videos you do
make each video about one of those facts
and see if anything sticks yeah yeah
yeah because you you'll have plenty more
where that
comes from you know and it's also nice
because i think a lot of people suffer
from just
sort of writer's block but if you say
like you
have to come up with 10 facts about
yourself that can eliminate that
and then if you say okay each of those
facts you have to write a bit about
you know three minutes or like uh just
three bullet points even
it's something you can complete in a day
and again get that momentum
how do you how do you create so much how
do you generate so many ideas dude just
scrolling through your feed
every idea is just like a hitter and
it's so like specific and well
written and executed like what it what
is like
now the creative process behind this
machine you've built
well yeah thank you i mean actually when
i get off of this
i'm going to get on a creative meeting
with
um my the producers and
um and you know
just gonna throw a bunch of ideas off
the wall and see what
what sticks like and it's it's
you know everything there's no bad ideas
it's like bizarre ideas stupid ideas
things you know are stupid but you're
gonna say anyway uh
because you never know they could make
like a even if it's not gonna make like
a three-minute sketch
it's it'll make maybe a tick tock you
know maybe it's worth trying
maybe it's dumb but maybe it inspires
something else so just having those
consistent
creative brainstorms and then also just
you know having
uh my notes section on my phone is just
obvious
as i'm sure every comedian says is just
full of a bunch of half-baked terrible
ideas but
at some point they could inspire
something
uh down the road so how many people are
on your team now
ah two two oh two in addition to you
yeah yeah yeah uh so you guys will meet
up like
so basically you're walking through the
world as funny people
looking for ideas and then you'll all
meet together once a week or something
and like
see well it sticks yeah i mean um we
we work together all week like because
we have the podcast so
someone edits that and then you know we
have a weekly video someone's saying
that so everyone does different
jobs in the producing aspect and then
cool
you know and then just yeah once a week
or yeah it's pretty much once a week if
we can
uh we just go through these ideas
upcoming videos
and the more you can stay a couple
videos ahead too the more you can be
more creative and none that space of oh
man i need to think of something you
know
yeah same thing with podcasting if you
yeah if you're if it's weekly i mean
you've done over 300 of these and i've
i've been up at like 4 00 a.m to release
this at 8 00 a.m
you know like yeah i've done a lot and
and that's the thing
too is to try and avoid that because i
think that just leads to the burnout and
that's the other
you know end of it and i'm not great at
that part of burnt down many times but
you know if you can just be in that more
creative oh it's a couple of weeks off
we don't need this or uh
you're getting the sleep you need simple
stupid stuff like that does help so
yeah that's it seems and that's
something looking at the team aspect and
this is something i heard andrew schultz
talk about
was comedy almost being more of a team
sport now
and he's like you can do it alone but
he's like you're competing against us
you know and he has like three other
people on his team
at least in front of the camera i'm not
sure how many he has all together
but it seems more than ever comedy is
becoming more of a team sport which is
interesting
it's so much more fun that way i have
people i collaborate with
and it look it makes sense because
you're getting
their followers they're getting your
followers you're both rising you cross
post the video
uh facebook and those things like to see
collaboration so it only helps
and uh the more you see is like there's
enough for everybody
uh just the better it first of all it's
true
there's not a any limits on um
you know what it a million people can
sell out dates there are plenty of dates
on the books
uh at all these clubs there's plenty of
time for people to get out there
if you have an audience that'll come see
you and
there's just more people being added to
the world every day so
you know uh so
get those fans before our population
goes extinct you know so
uh we'll be we'll be fine but it's way
more
fun to collaborate i have so much more
fun doing videos with other people than
i do just doing them by myself
yeah you said something interesting
there with facebook likes to see
collaborations
is is it something within the algorithm
if they see like accounts
connections yeah you know
now that i say that i don't know if
that's still a thing in the algorithm
i believe it was at one point i believe
youtube also had it because
you know they create those creator
centers and facebook
a buddy of mine went to a meeting of
facebook creators that they put together
and they do i mean facebook likes it
brings more people to the
uh to the platform i think and they have
cross posting
uh methods enabled i doubt they would
have those enabled if that didn't
if that wasn't something they wanted you
to do but yeah it just
it makes sense to uh find other people
creating and
put your brain together and it's the
same reason musical artists feature on
each other's
uh albums and all that and uh
you know it's fun and it brings
audiences in
yeah i think that is the old mindset in
comedy is like
every man for himself i think it is more
collaborative and that's the culture of
the hot breath of verse here is positive
and supportive
because when i started 11 years ago it i
was alone and confused
and there wasn't anyone an open mic who
was like here let me let me
help you out here i mean it was just all
uphill and i'm like
if i can create a platform for comics to
not have to
go through all that unnecessary
suffering just for the sake of like
proving
whatever it's like no if you can just
get a safe space to develop as a comic
you're gonna get that much funnier
faster and comedy's better for it
exactly i mean look i'm sure that there
is a you know
a certain comedian out there who doesn't
like hearing any of this but
that's cool that's cool like you don't
have to
you don't have to like it i've just
found it's easier and i tried doing the
open mic thing for a long long time and
here's the truth but i wasn't that good
doing open mic i was okay you know i had
a decent eight minutes
but uh it wasn't until i ended up
like selling a show that i did my first
headline thing and
at that point i only had eight minutes
but once you develop it enough and you
run it enough times and you get up on
stage and you do it
and then you do it like i don't know 300
more times if you have
you know over the next year and a half i
mean you become
really good really fast so i think it
only helps you become a better
stand-up to get that stage time i mean
i'm not saying anything groundbreaking
there but
it's an easy way to do it and a fun way
to do it so why not
yeah oh and christopher graves is saying
hi from wisconsin
oh nice uh you know tell him to watch
out for deer
that's what we got to tell them i tell
them that tell us folks i says hi
okay all right real good and it's it's a
heat wave out there it's
45 degrees today it is just balmy
i might go go tan yeah well we got to
keep her moving here
uh so uh well fight
you like that yeah you like it as well
well placed yep
thank you very good part part of me
thinks i'm the dab
i don't know the like i i went through
i released a comedy special called the
trophy husband
and i was like this is the brand but
then my wife
isn't she doesn't want to be in the
picture at all like so i feel like
me being the trophy husband it kind of
puts some sort of
pressure on her you know so this
is the funny thing you say my wife
doesn't want to be in the picture at all
so
okay i know it was the wrong podcast for
that i think
no i get it but you're developing your
stuff just around your
yourself yeah i don't yeah i don't want
is she i want to take her out she was in
the special and whatnot but i want for
the next
uh next chapter of my career i want to
make sure she's insulated and not
involved in any
yeah i think in the material side so now
i've been looking like i've been trying
to like
dab and hashtag bring back the dab and
like i've been like
it's an interesting hashtag i've yet to
uh hashtag it but
i like where you're going with that
that was such a mmm i
can't say i approve of that but i i mean
i'm excited to see where you may go with
it
well what i'm gonna do is list ten
things about me ten facts and i'm gonna
work from there
uh there you go there you go yeah that's
that's
that's the only advice i really offered
so you know yeah but maybe your um
is the part in your career where people
told you to get a voice coach and you're
like i'll just make an
entire company like and i'll just make a
social media movement about it instead
you know so never mind no no no never
listen to
anybody but yourself that is 100
deal so i hope you didn't read too much
into my um
you know i i i was very
fond of your dab i just didn't want to
say it out loud i did
i'm just glad it wasn't an oh that's
what i'm yeah
oh say oh pie dab
all right not too bad there all right
we're working it out here we're working
it out
uh and before we get in into some
people's questions here
the the the last thing i wanted to ask
you about is your business sense
like it's one thing to be able to get
views
and like create content that connects
with people
but like then to you really seem to be
savvy about
how you i mean you collaborate i mean
you have your own beer your merch like
music like can maybe put some game out
there about
like the business side of what you're
doing and how comics can learn from that
i think yeah you just don't get too
overwhelmed by it but
um you know as soon as you have an
audience you have people who will
be interested in buying shirts or
whatever and
you know we really tried to do ours in a
way that was like representative
wisconsin so
i'm representing the midwest so all the
stuff is like made
in the u.s and then also printed in
wisconsin which
also is a terrible business move so uh
you know
it's uh it's great makes you feel good
but it's not the most business
uh savvy thing you can do um but that's
okay i think it's a it's a good thing to
do and
i i don't know i think basically though
you've you learned the business side as
you move through this
and it's not a big deal if you screw
something up
because you're basically as soon as
things start to take off for the point
to the point of where you can make money
you're essentially going to college for
business
you know because at least you'll fail
enough tests that that
feels like the truth you know like i
failed enough things on that side
but don't let it get the best of you
just keep doing your best to
so are you are you like as you're
developing ideas for your
sketches and such are you developing
ideas for business or is it is it more
kind of involved
people like oh yeah yeah
no people will approach me yeah i really
don't see what happens
yeah yeah i'm not um going out seeking
um
too much of it and that's the nice thing
it's kind of like when you keep focusing
on what what you do well
uh and what i do well is not really
business or that thing but you focus on
what you do well and then people who do
other things well will
hopefully come to you so okay yeah
because that's where i'm at a point
where this like
show is like man money's
cool like especially like in in a
pandemic
and there's no live shows it's like yeah
you know money
money would be cool you know so yeah
part of me is like
how can we monetize this but it is also
the other idea is build it and they will
come
as well yeah and i mean
i think a few friends do podcasts and
you can get involved in a network
uh i don't know if whatever you do just
i think it's probably you want to
maintain ownership
but then um you can get plugged into
like a thing where they sell ads over a
bunch of different
podcasts i don't know much about that
but i've heard people doing that
yeah i but again or you know
even just you have merch for the pod you
have shirts and stuff
yeah and so that then that's easy enough
to just
advertise to folks um listening
yeah true true that yeah that's another
thing i have i i'll
i just don't tell people that's another
thing yeah
oh yeah you tell me at the beginning and
at the end and
you know you yeah i don't know that's
hard for me too i kind of forget
that yeah that's well it's just cool to
see that's why i like interviewing
people
who like have success as you're you're
learning i mean we're all still
trying to figure it out like no one has
like the exact formula it's like
i sell things it works sometimes like
people have ideas they bring to me like
it's um it's just we're all we're all
trying to figure it out as we go in a
lot of ways
yeah yeah that is kind of it and it's
always changing
it's changing uh what's right today is
gonna be wrong tomorrow so it just
keeps you on your toes what do you think
is cause you've been creating content a
long time what do you think is
next uh in the content game or what have
you seen to be consistently
still a pillar of content that comics
can start to apply
um you're saying like
what what trend or what whatever
yeah maybe like yeah ask two questions
at once there uh maybe like what do you
see as
next up in like media like
platforms or what how we create content
things like that
well uh kind of unfortunately it's a lot
of this vertical video stuff
which i don't think is as fun um but
it's
you know you can have fun with it so
instagram reels and tick tock instagram
is doing the thing facebook always does
which is just try and
buy up anyone else who's successful
either buy them up or steal their ideas
so they're ripping off tick tock with
those um
with those shorter uh the real videos
so just make 30 second videos that's
what both of those platforms are really
uh saying yeah this is what you got to
do
so i just make those short videos see if
you can get some traction on either
platform
and then you'll be set when the next
thing comes i'm not smart enough to know
two steps down the way
i just tend to know like what you can do
to improve your viewers
today uh but yeah that's kind of are you
familiar with youtube shorts yet
yeah i mean actually i'm not that
familiar with it i saw
a thing on reddit about those but you
just basically upload your tic tocs and
hashtag shorts is that it
yeah i think they're it sounds like
they're making a move like
to really become almost like a more
short form
um platform because they're testing in
india and then they're gonna release
they're gonna like announce it in march
here in america but i think in india it
was actually a separate app
i believe it was like a youtube shorts
app
so they're making some sort of moves
there i'm not sure what
well we'll see we'll see if it's i mean
youtube has really not
been successful in much of anything
outside of just the video player
i think i mean it's obviously very
successful with more long-form
series but when it comes to this i'll be
interested to see if they can compete
with it or if it's going to be like
google hangouts
you know we're uh we're on zoom right
now so
yeah that's a great analogy yeah yeah
we'll see uh to get into a few questions
here we have a few more minutes kiddos
um ben webb uh is asking
[Music]
how are some ways you have been able to
get
more people to engage with your content
so that is something i've heard you talk
about is like creating content that
connects
yeah how do you create that content that
connects
well i think putting things in that
people can relate to is a big
deal you know once you post your stuff
if there's a part you want to highlight
you know or a comment you want to
highlight i think that's important
you know like or there's something in
the
video itself that uh you can make
another joke
about like it's kind of a opportunity
for another joke and then people have to
watch a video to get
that and then they comment on it or just
when people say something just comment
back
at him treat the people you have the
fans you have it's almost like serve the
fans you have
uh right there not the fans you're
trying to get
but as you serve your fans more fans
will come
oh and you're saying so if there's a
joke within the video you almost make
that part of the caption of the video to
enjoy yeah
yeah yeah yeah you kind of it's like a
it'd be a topper and stand up or
something like that oh
oh very nice nice
oh we just got a two dollar super chat
from brent
whoa talking about monetizing yo
i seriously that's two bucks i'll send
you an invoice for one dollar of that
i'm i'm gonna do it that's a finder's
fee these are my
fans joel
[Laughter]
that's hilarious so uh the
let's do a few more here uh fat thor
podcast
is asking how and when did
you do dad and holderness
start creating together so
yeah it started off i started creating
with the you betcha guy miles
and then he had created something with
taylor who's the dude dead guy
so uh i was in la um
for something and i hit up taylor
uh or taylor reached out to me saying he
had worked with miles so it's kind of
that whole thing and then
taylor asked us if we wanted to do this
husbands of target video
pen was in that video so you know you
just kind of
one leads to another and yeah
that's a great thing to do if you can
that's actually we're going to talk
about as well as just more collabs and
stuff like that this year
yeah yeah that had me almost thinking
like someone at
my level is it
would it be like i guess you collab
across the aisle in a sense almost like
i i wouldn't like reach out to you and
be like
yo will you lift me up type deal is it
more you kind of reach across
well i think you look for people at your
same following or a similar following
and the more the higher you go i think
or the
level of creator but i mean you can ask
anybody
and but the more you go you want to
bring something else to the table like
can you bring a full script to the table
okay
like and then um the higher you go also
you want to like write that character
make that person like the star of it and
you're supporting in the sketch you know
but if you bring something that fits
it's also good writing
practice you know if you're into
screenwriting it's like writing a script
for
i don't know csi or whatever you write
in that style that format say i think
this would work great for you
um let me know if you want to do it you
know great
yeah well when i have an idea you betcha
all right
that's not your channel but still done
man
universal phrase i uh
bob kirk on average
is there an optimum time duration for
content
um you know on facebook
uh it's over three minutes um
and then uh you know tick tock
is shorter quicker better same with
reels
you know uh whatever you need to say to
get the joke and get out
facebook's algorithm just likes longer
videos
but and then i think youtube's algorithm
also
prefers longer videos i think podcasts
actually work well on youtube
because the longer it goes the more ads
it can serve
so yeah it's it's all yeah platform
specific yeah
all right uh maybe two more here real
quick uh
lua's ark this is ash bt-dub
with a smiley face you know ash nice
nice ash
uh yes i do with the smiley face right
yeah that that's her last name actually
it's ash smiley face you know her last
name it's a family name
yeah yeah come from a long line of faces
[Laughter]
um ash is asking how long did it take
for either of you
to realize people came to the place you
were performing
primarily to see you perform
um good question yeah for me it was
it went from people that i paid for
their ticket
at in a bringer show i was like it'll be
free
you know yeah it was a bringer show i
was just getting them in
uh it went from that to selling out
uh theater that's how quick it was so
the video pops and then now you're just
video pops
and yeah selling out yeah so
um but yeah so for me it was not
doing the clubs until people were like
oh i'm here to see you
it was that other way so yeah i mean
mine
i did a self-produced tour i did a
trophy husband tour
promoting my special 2019
and like in houston actually i had
a few i mean by several i mean there's
probably five people that came out
to see me which was really cool but i
2020 was like
my second long run on the road where i
was starting to build email list
and like a somewhat of like people maybe
next time three people would have come
to see me or something you know so like
i was more on the road route and then
quarantine hit so
i'll get back to you ash when i'm in
your town and you can be the first
there but that's part of the hustle
that is yeah that email list more
important than you think
yep okay you own that list yeah
instagram could close tomorrow
i know yeah um so brent
to we'll just do the final question here
brent with a two dollar super chat is
asking
how do you keep it fun when it starts to
feel like
work um yeah
i think that you just get
creative and goofy with it and you just
look for things that'll make you laugh
and uh just kind of follow the passion
because a ton of it feels like work
and just don't set the expectation that
it's not gonna
feel like work because i mean whether
it's taxes
or you know uh the business end of it
there's it's
or you know facebook or youtube
demonetize you for
some false claim on your page
i mean it's gonna feel like work a bunch
of days so just expect that
and then uh you know just be grateful
for the days i feel like
they're fun you know and be grateful
that that work
is what you want to do and it's not like
working and like renting cars or
something you know
yeah yeah definitely uh if you're coming
up
you know always get a shitty job
initially you know uh just for
i mean whether you're 16 or whatever i
i've been working since i was
uh young pretty young but i think
working so many bad jobs really
reiterates how what was your worst luck
you were
i would say stacking milk
um at the at century yeah
i wasn't uh yeah i was not
you know for a guy from wisconsin i just
wasn't that interested in
the dates on the milk cartons so uh i
got yelled at
every day and then uh yeah i burned some
brats after that and then it was
game over i was like 12 at the time so
that sounds legal
yeah that sounds legal yeah i was 12.
burning brats it's totally safe i might
have been 13. i could legally work i'm
pretty sure
i mean they hired me man that doesn't
always say much but
anyway it's not around anymore so there
you go
what was your like worst bomb is there a
bomb that you just will never forget
oh yeah i know it was the first time i
was doing stand up
first time i was doing stand-up i just
wrote this hilarious bit
expected it to crush got up on stage
froze forgot it deer in the headlights
i yeah and then i eventually just
started
improvising and got a little bit of a
laugh but it was like a laugh off of a
terrible terrible bomb it was a well
that didn't work right
when well that didn't work because your
biggest laugh in a set you know you
bombed pretty good
uh and then it just took me months to
get back on stage after that
oh you took a big break from that bomb i
i did
but then what happened was i needed
uh to host an event so i was like i'm
not gonna do this again at this event so
i really just forced myself to
get up on stage a lot so
well this is uh thanks for getting up
and doing this
show man seriously oh absolutely thanks
for having me i appreciate it
yeah we always end these with like uh
two things
it's um one what is what is like your
best advice what is your favorite advice
for like comics that you could bestow
upon us
like closing advice for the next
generation of comics out there
uh just keep creating that's it keep
creating if you're
i create every day and uh it could be
some small could be something big but
create every day and uh have fun with it
great every day and have fun with it and
the final would you mind
uh looking at the camera saying your
name and why people should listen to hot
breath
yep uh hey there folks it's charlie host
of the man to walk minute you should be
listening to hot breath
because you know it's cold out there and
a little hot breath feels good
on your hands when you're trying to plow
okay real good
okay ladies and gentlemen charlie barons
show them some love thank you so much
for taking the time to do this charlie
you the man
all right appreciate you we'll talk to
you soon
you